Shanta good evening to you it was one of
those were not in Kansas moments anymore
after months of denials that President
Trump had anything to do with the payoff
to store B Daniels came word today that
well yes he did and then there was word
that the president's personal attorney
Michael Cohen was under surveillance
limit miss Kidd was the latest in a day
of bombshells a report that in the week
leading up to the raid on Trump personal
attorney Michael Cohen Cohen was the
subject of a federal wiretap that may
have tracked a call from the White House
I'm not sure when the last conversation
took place and I would refer you to the
president's outside counsel about any
concerns
neither the president's attorneys nor
representatives for Michael Cohen could
confirm the wiretap the presidential
lawyer Rudy Giuliani went off on the DOJ
saying if true anybody who says that I'm
exaggerating when I say that this is an
out-of-control investigation and they're
acting like stormtroopers
give me a break baby they prove it every
day Giuliani blasted the possibility of
a wiretap is a blatant transgression of
attorney-client privilege saying I am
waiting for the Attorney General to step
in in his role as defender of Justice
and put these people under investigation
can't possib last night Giuliani threw a
hand grenade into the Kohen
investigation telling sean hannity the
president paid cohen back for that 130
thousand dollar payment to stormy
Daniels so they funneled it through the
law firm funnel through offer him and
the president repaid it the stunning
admission appeared to contradict
previous statements one from Michael
Cohen in February who said neither the
Trump organization nor the Trump
campaign reimbursed me for the payment
either directly or indirectly and
another April 5th from the president
aboard Air Force One
but Giuliani insists President Trump
didn't know he was paying coming back
for paying stormy Daniels the
reimbursement said Giuliani was for
expenses that Cohen did not itemize and
while Giuliani insisted the payment to
Daniels did not benefit the campaign he
also seemed to say it did imagine if
that came out on October 15th John 16 a
little of the you know last debate with
Hillary clips so to make it go away they
they made this home he didn't even ask
Cohen did Cohen made it go away he did
his job stormy Daniels lawyer Michael
avenatti was stunned by Giuliani's
acknowledgment of the payoff our case
just got exponentially better in the
last 24 hours
I've been saying this all along this is
about a cover-up
it's about lies told the American people
it's about people trying to pull the
wool over people's eyes that citizens in
this country the new revelations through
into chaos what was meant to be a day of
faith at the White House the president
hosting religious leaders to celebrate
the National Day of Prayer we are proud
of our religious heritage and as
president I will always protect
religious liberty in that spirit
president Trump signed an executive
order to establish the new White House
faith and opportunity initiatives the
office will focus on protecting
religious freedom the faith initiative
will help design new policies that
recognize the vital role of faith in our
families communities and our great
country but at the same time President
Trump was urging quiet reflection
his newly reconstituted legal team
adopted a far more aggressive posture
after Rudy Giuliani referred to FBI
agents who conducted the search on
Michael Cohen as storm troopers James
Comey tweeted I know the New York FBI
there are no storm troopers there just a
group of people devoted to the rule of
law and the truth our country would be
better off if our leaders tried to be
like them rather than comparing them to
Nazis Giuliani's response to Comey
he's a sensitive little baby late this
afternoon sources told Fox News producer
Jake Gibson that while Michael Cohen was
under surveillance his phones were not
tapped than his calls were not
quartered investigators used a device
called a pen register to record the
numbers of the calls that Cohen was
making from his phone and logged the
duration of those calls but those phone
calls themselves Shannon were never
listened to all right John Roberts live
for us at the White House thank you John